imagine if we could control earthquakes
and tsunamis to generate power or maybe
even terraform every planet in the solar
system these are just a couple of the
things that might happen if human
civilization was too advanced in the
future so how can humans get to this
point
what other advancements will happen and
what makes us think we'll even progress
this far this is what if and here's what
would happen if we became a type one
civilization global civilizations can be
categorized into what's known as the
Kardashev scale this measures a
civilizations ability to use all the
energy available to it and is scaled
from one to three
currently humanity doesn't even reach
type one civilization this is because
humans don't use all the forms of energy
on earth we use wood coal and oil but
there's a lot more so what would change
if humanity evolved into one of these
types of civilizations being a type one
civilization means we would have
complete control over all the energy on
earth this means that we'd say goodbye
to fossil fuels since they're limited
and unsustainable instead we could use
the wind sunlight and water for our
energy needs and since this energy is so
accessible you may no longer need to pay
for your power bill in a type one
civilization we've continuously be using
energy it would be as essential as
oxygen
we would also start using natural
disasters to our advantage
tsunamis could be used to produce energy
and earthquakes could potentially be
used to terraform parts of the world
with us having complete control over our
planets energy sources we could also
control the weather if an area of the
world were suffering through a drought
we could disperse rain clouds over it
and bring it back to life humanity could
also say goodbye to global warming as
we'd be able to bring the atmosphere
back to carbon neutral and control our
planets temperatures casualties from
natural disasters would also be reduced
as we'd be able to predict when and
where they might happen and not only
that but we'd be able to live on places
on earth we'd never have dreamed of
before like in the water as well as in
climates that used to be unsuitable for
us humans yep living in a type one
civilization would be pretty great but
with things being this perfect we might
get a little bored so what if we took
humanity one step further and became a
type two civilization or even a type 3 a
type two civilization means we could
harness the energy of the Sun and use it
not just on earth but throughout our
services
we could use its power to travel to and
terraform Mars or even a planet like
Neptune becoming a type 3 civilization
would allow us to use all the energy in
the galaxy and since the Kardashev scale
was invented in the 1960s scientists
have come up with potential fourth and
fifth types of civilizations this is
where things get a little tricky
scientists aren't ready to fully define
these as their past our current
understanding of physics but it is safe
to say that becoming either a type 4 or
type 5 civilization means we could
harness the energy of the entire
universe and be able to travel it with
ease and becoming a type 5 civilization
means we'd all be practically God's we
could control and manipulate the
universe in whichever way we please
there's no telling when we might evolve
to these levels of civilization but
experts generally agree that humanity
might be able to reach type 1 in the
next 100 years or so but that's only
assuming that humanity lives long enough
in the first place with global warming
getting worse and worse and humanity not
taking the correct measures to stop it
fast enough there's no telling what
might happen to become a type one
civilization maybe we need to go back in
time but we'll leave that story for
another what-if
you